[Music]
young lady lover on the top of the
world can put my trust in all the things
that of
heard somewhere inside you're still girl
I used to know but I can feel you
letting
go how's it going to
be when you don't know
[Music]
me how's it going to
be when you you don't know
[Music]
me I used to run inside that Circle you
will but that little bubbles bound to
burst in a
bit going with goodbye to the man you
used to know can you feel feel me let
him
go how's it going to
[Music]
be when you don't know
me how's it going to
[Music]
be when you don't know me
Sun is setting on a lonely road
now the Mystic only knows the curse you
can I can't stand the things you happy
you found but I feel
like I'll be cool
at
last CU this just how it's got to
[Music]
be you don't know me do
you how's it going to
[Music]
be when you don't know me no
me
[Music]
no thank you beautiful thank you very
much